hey what's up guys my name is a channel
I haven't done one of these reaction
videos in a while but I was just you
know working aka just browsing YouTube
this uh fine morning and this popped up
on my feed on another engine 5.2
next-gen Graphics Tech demo state of
unreal 2023 this is from GDC this year
which is currently going on uh I kind of
missed GDC I went to jdc in 2018 when I
was still working for EA because they
flew me out there and I remember
specifically going to an Unreal Engine
presentation like in the flesh in San
Francisco and this was when like
real-time Ray tracing was like just
coming out so it was really really cool
to see I think they showed like the
Stormtrooper demo back then like some
kind of Star Wars scene it was really
really cool to see that real-time Ray
tracing so it was crazy how much has
changed in five years I mean I guess
five years is a decent amount of time
but anyway Unreal Engine 5.2 next gen
Graphics Tech demo haven't seen this yet
obviously let's take a look I'll have
the video linked
rendering and the fortnite team used
those features to ship battle royale
chapter 4. at the same time Jacob over
there and the team at qixel were
experimenting with what's possible for
photoreal foliage environments as well
kind of okay I just I immediately want
to add a few things here right so first
of all foliage rendering is not
something that unreal engines 5 really
supported in terms of with all of its
latest nanite and Lumen features out of
the box because for those of you who are
like rendering Engineers or enthusiasts
I guess who understand how that works
foliage rendering
in fact many different parts of a
scene's rendering technology especially
like the so like not the standard meshes
in Geometry but like all the kind of
almost effects so things like particles
things like well foliage obviously
things like I don't know water like all
these kind of special effects that
aren't just like and I'm calling them
special effects even though that is
usually a term that we use for other
things but all of those kind of special
rendering scenarios they can be an
entirely different base that has to run
through a completely different pipe
pipeline has like lots and lots of
specific edge cases and specific ways
that things have to be handled so
naturally when you introduce something
as big as Lumen or nanites it's like
each section of the scene's rendering
like the foliage versus the the normal
kind of static measures or dynamic
measures or whatever each kind of area
needs like almost its own Department to
just be like okay we're gonna we're
gonna make this work we're gonna make
this compatible we're gonna run this now
I don't literally mean Department like
within the company that needs to work on
that usually you'd expect it to just be
the the team that obviously make makes
like the Lumen Tech in the first place
to add it to like all different areas
but my point is something might run out
of the box and work really well in like
the base case but then you try and make
it work with foliage rendering and
you're like Ugh nothing works so that
was just something I remember not being
a thing I feel like they added this in
5.1 though maybe I'm wrong haven't been
following along with this too closely
but it definitely wasn't around in
Unreal Engine five like nanite or Lumen
like didn't quite support foliage
rendering in the same way that it
obviously does now now the other thing I
want to note is qixel right so part of
the reason why these scenes look so
detailed and so amazing is because
Unreal Engine made the very very wise
decision of buying qixel back in the day
I guess I'll just say epic games did and
qixel is this huge library of assets so
like these plans that you're seeing like
the the kind of art assets that we use
to construct this scene are from qixel
and the reason why that's such a smart
decision and it's just such a good thing
to do is because at the end of the day a
game engine is like absolutely nothing
without assets like if you don't have
good art assets that you can pop into
the engine to create scenes you're gonna
get nowhere right the engine's only
going to be as good as the assets that
are fed into it it's kind of like having
like the US I don't know a
state-of-the-art photo printer like you
have the best photo printer in the world
but you're just creating little images
in paint and then sending it to the
photo printer it's like yes like they
will kind of kind of look good like
they'll you know they'll the color will
be good and like it'll be what you make
it right like it'll still look kind of
good in a way but obviously like if you
compare that to you know uh 100
megapixel photo that an artist like
there's some some professional
photographer took of like I don't know
mountains in the real world or something
and it just they color graded it they
made it look perfect and you feed that
through your photo printer obviously
that's going to look so much better so a
lot of what you're seeing here is
obviously also thanks to the amazing art
assets that quixel provides uh and just
the artists in general that put this
together because that yeah that can't be
understated
functionality that we've been built by
the way as I mentioned I will link the
video below so if you don't want to hear
me talk just watch the video thing for
Unreal Engine
so Jacob's here the latest functionality
that we've been building for Unreal
Engine
so Jacob's here with us today in the
unreal editor let's explore the
environment and what better way to do
that than off-roading and what better
way to off-road than an arivian r1t
now rivian uses unreal to power their
instrument cluster including 3D
visualization of their vehicles let's
work with them to bring the r1t to life
in this experience because some real
world
show a thing on my way all right so
we're building tools for interactive and
dynamic worlds so here we have chaos
physics simulating rocks that tumble as
we drive over them leaves Bend out of
the way I was just about to ask like
what how Dynamic this scene was meaning
like if you drive over this Branch you
know is this completely static or is
this something that will crumble and
break now for the rendering side of
things that's not a big deal just
because you know Lumen will recalculate
stuff kind of dynamically and even
though it might take like a few frames
it's still gonna be able to do that
versus obviously just statically baked
lighting which used to be kind of more
or less the norm back in the day and
we're shifting from that obviously into
a more dynamic system but I like I don't
know too much about how unreal engines
physics like their chaos physics system
works but like you know this might be
like extremely high quality in terms of
like how many triangles it's actually
made up of right because if it's nanite
then of course you could this could be
like a million triangles but you're not
really gonna probably simulate a million
triangles in the physics system if you
need to kind of have some kind of
dynamic fracturing and actual physics as
well so that's why like I'm curious like
if he drove off-road and actually went
through stuff and broke stuff whether or
not that would kind of hold up or try to
run over a tree or a rock but they did
mention yeah that the Rocks obviously
are Dynamic but anyway maybe I'm just
getting ahead of myself because maybe
he's going to do that we also added some
real-time movies and moving a bit wow
fluid simulation
yeah
to set up unreal's chaos vehicle model
to simulate the suspension of the truck
and how the electric motors Drive each
individual wheel chaos also simulates
how the tires compress and deform and
meta sounds enabled the team to
precisely re-synthesize the sounds of
the electric motors and mix them with
the ambisonics of the jungle
so rivien provided us with a highly
detailed model of the truck oh good here
we go so this is this shows the nanite
kind of uh we'll just shows triangles
right it's interesting that these guys
are black
so that tells me that maybe this isn't
nanite this foliage
um maybe but but see this this is though
so that's where this is black maybe
certain things are maybe certain
foliages are like night and some of them
are not but either way it gives you like
some indication of how crazy like
detailed these scenes are
about 71 million polygons
in real time thanks to nanite right so
this model this model of the truck is 71
million polygons they're in real and
interestingly he doesn't say triangles
he says polygons and that is an
interesting choice of words because
obviously they come down to being
triangles at the end of the day but if
he's saying polygons you know obviously
if you have if you have polygons that
have more like vertices than three then
that's technically kind of more detailed
when you convert into triangles because
you have more than 71 million triangles
like if if this was quads for example
this truck then obviously when you
convert that into two triangles you kind
of end up with twice the amount of
triangles so yeah that's interesting
thanks to nanite
I'm sure it probably is triangles but
now the rivian not only looks incredibly
realistic because of luminance why is
this quality so bad the Montana ap60 I
mean this is IGN so you know what I
expect but also it's materials and today
we're introducing substrate our new
material framework okay subscribe
and to better demonstrate it let's talk
I swear I've been in this Hall I think
this is the hole that they did the the
paint 2018 presentation in well it looks
similar anyway now of course you can't
order a rivian with opal body panels but
opal was the internal code name for this
project and also a really great
demonstration of substrates capabilities
yeah wow the base layer models the
iridescence refraction and Reflections
that occur inside of an opal yes they
got multi-layered kind of materials here
there's a layer representing the
polished surface and how light is
absorbed as it travels through that
clear layer of varying depths really
good and now we can add back on the dust
and dirt layers
and notice how the reflection changes
when interacting with the dust layer and
that there are no artifacts along the
transition from dirt to dust to opal
so substrate is more expressive enabling
artists to create materials like this
with different shading models and
compose and layer those materials as
they see fit
all right let's uh head on out Jacob on
my way
yeah this is a real-time camera which is
very substrate materials that are
similar to the current Unreal Engine
shading model cost a thousands live
shading model costs about the same but
now artists have the freedom to author
more complex materials for extremely
detailed use cases like in cinematics
and in film
so we're going to drive under this
Fallen yeah that's the other thing that
I keep forgetting about like obviously
Unreal Engine is not just for games you
know like Film Production like you know
like Mandalorian used Unreal Engine a
bunch which that reminds me I should get
around to watching season three but it's
just so cool to also kind of picture the
fact that these these improvements will
also be useful to that entire industry
right it's not just four games and four
real-time things so sometimes like when
you have a platform like Unreal Engine
that is so like diversely used like a
lot of these features that might not
even make sense to you as like you know
if you're into games and you're working
in the games industry you might be like
oh that's not never gonna run because
that's like terabytes of data and
whatever like the film industry might be
like no no no no no that that's perfect
for us because obviously their product
at the end of the day is a frame is a
frame of video and your product is an ex
is like all the raw assets and
everything that you have to bundle up
with the game because you need to ship
that so it's two completely different
sides three here and everything that
you've seen up to this point was
painstakingly hand built by the
environment team yeah everything that's
what I was gonna say like the artists
obviously did an absolutely amazing job
on this and it's crazy how much worse
that would this would look without
talented artists since that fallen tree
has been built using our brand new
experimental Suite of procedural content
generation oh wow okay that's awesome
entire Leaf engine better flexible
deterministic and artist driven our
guiding principle in building these
systems was to empower artists to make
tools for artists oh great they're going
to show this as well yeah I was gonna
say like hand making stuff like this
like whilst obviously you can get a
really really good result especially if
you have good reference material like if
they actually went out to the forest you
know and they took some photos and they
wanted to kind of recreate something
like that like that's really important
to do because when you have reference
material like that you can be like oh
you know there's clusters of rocks tend
to be in this pattern right if you're
just going from your mind and trying to
like be like oh what does a forest look
like yeah I guess I could just put a a
rock there or some dirt here or some
Moss there or a fallen Branch there like
that can be really really difficult like
you need to have some kind of reference
right to create these scenes and
actually make them look realistic
because otherwise they won't quite look
right but obviously that's very
difficult and extremely time consuming
and expensive when you picture when you
think about the fact that those artists
need to spend so much time on this right
so obviously doing this stuff
procedurally which is what he's talking
about kind of having the computer having
having like Unreal Engine kind of be
like I'll just give me like a set of
rules ultimately and I will generate
this for you myself that can
dramatically speed up workflows and of
course that could reduce some of the
character from it because if you think
about like a forest if you're trying to
create a certain feel for a game and you
really want it to feel a certain way or
it needs to look a certain way or there
needs to be like all these paths and
trails like you want to fine tune every
aspect of it even if that's the case
like using procedural generation as a
starting point and tweaking it rather
than starting from scratch as an artist
and building everything yourself that's
also a major help and I'm also curious
like because AI is becoming so I guess
popular and useful you know these days
with stuff like chat GPT like I wonder
if you could just you know use the power
of AI to be like generate me a forest
that actually looks real you know or
like I want like this particular Forest
you know from like this place in Europe
or something like generate me that
forest and it will automatically know
like what trees to use like how the
environment and the climate kind of
mutates that I guess that would be
really interesting I think because you
could probably get something that feels
a lot more natural than potentially you
know procedural generation which can
make things a little bit weird but
anyway let's see how it works yeah a
procedural assembly to the world
and the cool thing is that it
communicates look what those things
appear thank you
yeah that's really helpful
pretty cool I mean the thing is like you
know he's saying procedural assembly but
and people are clapping and like yeah
it's cool and it looks great and it's
really cool to see a world this detailed
and that realistic looking just being
edited like that like that's really cool
like just watching this is cool because
you can't really replicate this in any
other tool or any other platform really
right like to this quality as well like
it's that is really cool to see but
um like at the end of the day what did
he do he dragged something in like it's
really hard to picture like what this
actually is you know because obviously
like even the thumbnail shows
like that Island kind of shape that he
ended up
putting in so clearly like you know how
procedural was this like I'm guessing
the actual structure wasn't procedural
but I guess the way that it kind of in
like you know integrated with the world
so Jacob maybe was procedural procedural
assembly because you can see like how it
seamlessly Blended actually it's
interesting to go through this frame by
frame okay so this is it popping in
so that's that's like the first frame so
yeah not bad right but you can see
there's no grass here or anything
uh and then as we go frame by frame
forward you can see here that grass just
suddenly appears the shading is
constantly changing probably because
lumens recalculating everything
temporarily kind of frame by frame as
the frames go on it accumulates more and
more data and then suddenly these kind
of things appear for some reason I don't
know I guess that's governed in some
rules like inside the actual like
blueprint or whatever that they've
dragged in and then yeah some extra
foliage appears and stuff so I'm
guessing like I don't know like it's
hard to it's hard to really because it
didn't really explain it it's hard to
see the extent of the procedural
generation for this particular asset
um especially because I have a suspicion
from that thumbnail that it probably
already existed but it's still obviously
really cool how it seamlessly kind of
Blends in with the environment like that
and the cool thing is that it
communicates with other nearby
procedural elements in the scene yeah so
that's what he's saying it communicates
with nearby with other nearby procedural
elements in the scene which is really
the magic of it I guess because you can
plan the stuff in and just keep adding
stuff into your scene seamlessly
which is really really cool like the
creek bed so let's say a designer comes
by wants to direct the player to drive
to the left Jacob can simply move the
assembly to the right and everything
updates to accommodate that change
that's really cool yeah game design is
iterative so let's say the designer
comes back wants to give the player the
choice of going left or right again I
mean just to be clear like you know the
games industry has used tools like this
like extensively over the last decade
probably like procedural generation of
things like paths you know has been
around in Unreal Engine as well for a
long time and even even something like
you know for racing games being able to
like drag tracks around and have them
automatically obviously you know you can
you're playing like a game like Need For
Speed for example and that corner just
feels yeah it's a little bit too slow
like I need to make that corner sharper
like you know what are you going to do
rebuild the whole section manually like
no you'll just grab that kind of spline
node or whatever and you'll just push it
this way and then suddenly you get a
road that looks more like that and
everything else has just
you know kind of like what he showed
here everything else will just adapt and
it will procedurally kind of you know
you'll be able to do that because
otherwise like could you imagine like
testing and tweaking racing games like
this manually I mean I guess that's what
they had to do back in the day but like
these days like it's it makes sense
obviously to create tools like that and
it's not like the hardest thing in the
world to make something like this like
for a racing game to make sure that like
your track feels really good and on the
other hand you'd probably want to make
sure that it does feel good before the
artists go in with their detailing and
actually make the environment look like
finished art but I would say that the
impressive thing that we're seeing here
is not even so much like the interaction
with the environment and everything but
it's just the level of quality that like
that this like you know this truly does
look just like I guess perfect right it
like it doesn't look like something
that's been slapped on moved around and
like in two seconds it looks like
something that's been worked on for like
a week by a team and that's really
impressive let me move the assembly back
over
now the artist who created this assembly
also added some additional handles that
Jacob can use to Art direct where Rock
slides occur well as in the customize
the piece a little bit more make it a
little easier for the ravian yeah which
is like
I was gonna say like you'd probably also
build build in a bunch of tools to make
this kind of tweakable in the way that
you want so that it can be like used you
know within the context of the game or
experience you're trying to create and
what that process is like I don't know
and I'm suspecting they probably won't
show that so it would be interesting to
see how you know you would go about
creating this the rule set that governs
how this is kind of integrated and
generated as well as like these handles
you know how do you make that happen
drive by
so we started by hand crafting that
original part of the level to set the
visuals in art direction for the entire
piece and then built out procedural
tools that allowed the team to create a
much larger play Space much more quickly
now let's see how we can use these
procedural tools
to make larger sweeping changes to the
environment no it looks so good I just
love the fact like this is one of the
coolest things I guess about like
nanites is just how you can just have
you know those wide shots I think that's
really their most powerful shots right
when they can just kind of drag the
camera off and kind of you know you
don't see any lotting you don't see like
popping you just it just looks detailed
just looks great like that's just
amazing I love that so Jacob let's start
by removing some of the trees in this
area absolutely that's easy enough
actually
all right a little too much let's let's
have some trees back in okay and let's
also add in some Cliff formations give
it a little bit more variability
so the procedural systems are all
deterministic as Jacob is experimenting
with different sets of input parameters
once so he's got like this is called PCG
just trying to look at this I'm guessing
like I don't know if this is a built-in
thing to Unreal legend or this is like a
custom blueprint or something that is
created that obviously like it obviously
would be because these are very specific
parameters
maybe this is something that just kind
of ships with the engine lights you can
always go back to it and get out exactly
the same results yeah because the same
and the procedural systems aren't just
placing trees and rocks but also fog
cards bugs birds everything that's
needed to bring this environment to life
and everything that you've seen here
works at scale this environment is four
kilometers by four kilometers
if we hide all the procedural elements
we can see that original hand-built area
about 200 meters by 200 meters that's
funny we believe that there will always
be the need for hand building
environments so we design these
procedural systems that's good tools for
artists that work in concert with
hand-built content exactly and that's
what I was saying like it's so good to
have a starting point you know or like
some kind of ability you know to to use
this with an actual artist because at
the end of the day like you know this
looks great and this would be great as
like a backdrop but if you imagine like
a story driven game or something like
you know you're gonna you're gonna have
to have specific like visions that the
art director or whatever whoever's
writing the story might have right and
obviously if it's difficult to be like I
want this exactly you know and I want
this to feel like this I want it to look
like this then you know it's almost like
this procedural system doesn't matter
and doesn't work well for anything other
than like I need to create some terrain
for the background you know which again
usually would be crazy to have this
level of detail for that but because of
nanite and how it works that might
actually be feasible
so it's really good that you can use it
and the new procedure tools will be
available in experimental form in 5.2
and everything you've seen here is
running in the unreal editor in real
time on a developer machine with an
Intel 13900k CPU and Nvidia RTX 4090 GPU
so Jacob thanks for pretty beefy but
thank you very much Nick for having me
it's been a pleasure nice to be expected
all right so that's Unreal Engine 5.2
the presentation from jdc epic as always
let me know what you guys thought of
this video if you want me to take a look
at something else next time and I will
see you later goodbye